روسيا تتصدى لهجوم اوكراني واسع النطاق
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تعلن احباط هجوم
اوكراني على خمسه قطاعات من الجبهه في
اتجاه جنوب دونات
القوات الاوكرانيه تكونت من ست كتائب
ميكانيكيه وكتبتيه دبابات
القوات الاوكرانيه كانت تهدف لاختراق
دفاعاتنا في اكثر مناطق الجبهه ضعفا
برايها ولكنها لم تنجح بذلك هذا ما كشفه
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت مقتل 250
جنديا اوكرانيا على الاقل وتدمير 16 دبابه
واحدى وعشرين عربه قتال مصفحه
روسيا اعتبرت ان هذا هو الهجوم المضاد
المنتظر فيما التزمت اوكرانيا الصمت
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات